das unter abend gehört dem tatort und
das seit 1970 warum ist diese krimireihe
aber so erfolgreich wer schaut sie sich
an was fasziniert uns am bösen und
welche themen setzt der tatort darüber
diskutiere ich mit dem philosophen
wolfram eilenberger und dem schweizer
tatort kommissar reto flückiger alias
stefan gubser hair group sowie hat man
eigentlich tv-kommissar
man wird gecastet als schauspieler
es gibt eine redaktion die da die
oberhand hat und die sagen ja wir
möchten werden diesen und sie selbst
sagten gewissermaßen yes we can in
diesem fall habe ich sehr gerne gesagt
yes he can weil es im buch ein traum von
mir mal tatort kommissar zu werden wird
sie vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger
den einstieg zu finden als philosoph ist
nicht ganz klar weswegen man sich mit
dem tatort auseinandersetzt eigentlich
ist es für mich so dass ich mich für
alle dinge interessiere die mich
interessieren und bei sokrates gibt es
diesen satz ein ungeprüftes leben ist
ein schlechtes leben und wenn sich neun
bis 13 millionen menschen jeden sonntag
etwas ansehen dann denke ich kann man
auch als philosoph fragen was passiert
da eigentlich was ist das spezifische
welche bedürfnisse welche sehnsüchte
werden da befriedigt und da glaube ich
will dass der tatort doch doch sehr tief
wenn das was den menschen heute ausmacht
und was ihn fasziniert sie sprechen von
sokrates und in einem klassischen
philosophen aber eigentlich ist ja das
format des kriminalromans oder
kriminalgeschichte ein jüngeres thema ja
das stimmt die kriminalgeschichte oder
der krimi ist eigentlich erst der 200
jahren teil der westlichen kultur gibt
es neues 813 eine geschichte von hugo
von hofmannsthal die die erste
geschichte im deutschsprachigen raum ist
wenn sie sehen was in diesen 200 jahren
passiert ist mit diesen relativ junge
genre das ist das absolut dominante
genre in der westlichen welt geworden
also sowohl im film als auch im
buchmarkt wenn sie die nummer eins die
nummer zwei die nummer drei sehen dann
ist das meistens eine krimigeschichte
und daran glaube ich dass fragen schon
an was ist es dass das krimigenre so
attraktiv macht was sagt das über uns
aus dass alles was uns wirklich fesselt
mit einem mord und mit einer aufklärung
an das zu tun hat und eben genau diese
geschichte mordtat der suche nach dem
täter ist er quasi immer ein repetitives
motiv ist das nicht ein bisschen so dass
wenn man einen tatort gesehen hat dann
hat man alle gesehen
nein das glaube ich nicht also man kann
das format sicher nicht neu erfinden es
gibt mittlerweile
915 tatorte glaube ich aber der tatort
und ich glaube das ist ein teil des
erfolges des tatortes in diesen 40
jahren mit gewachsen also die die filme
die themen haben sich verändert die
filme die macht hat sich verändert die
schnelligkeit die schnittgeschwindigkeit
der look hat sich verändert und das ist
alles irgendwie hat sich 40 jahre lang
entwickelt zudem kommt der tatort in
glaube ich mittlerweile 13 verschiedenen
16 oder 16 verschiedenen ausgaben daher
das heißt also der zuschauer hat immer
die möglichkeit auf verschiedenen ebenen
zu schauen wie hat sich wo was
weiterentwickelt oder wie was passiert
mit denen figuren und ich glaube das
zusammen mit der zuverlässigkeit der
tatort hat denn er läuft seit eben über
40 jahren um 20.15 und jetzt neuerdings
auch um 20 5 im sf hat dazu beigetragen
dass das format zu erfolgreich aber die
veränderung also das ist eine dass sie
sich entwickelt mit der gesellschaft mit
den gesellschaften die uns umtreibt aber
auf der anderen seite sie haben also
auch angesprochen dieses ritual immer
sonntags um 8 basiert und das signet das
würde mich unternehmen dieses
unveränderte signet seit 1970 was für
eine rolle spielt es genau für den
mythos staat also diese langlebigkeit
oder der erfolg hat sich ja auch was mit
dem sendeplatz zu tun wenn sie am
sonntagabend um 20 uhr sehen dass es
fast eine spiegelung des kirchgang am
sonntagabend um 10 uhr morgens und was
geschah in der kirche man hat sich
reflektiert auf den oft auf woche man
hat sich geeinigt von den sünden es
wurde einem vergeben und in gewisser
weise funktioniert der tatort ähnlich
wir wissen die böse welt ist da draußen
gewissen das geschehen verbrechen und
jeden sonntagabend spiegel als spiegel
zum kirchgang sehen wir dass das böse
eingedämmt werden kann dass wir darüber
nachdenken können und in diesem sinne
ist der tatort eine art baldrian oder
das sehr beruhigend ist dass es uns
jedes sonntag wieder versichert dass
diese welt vom bösen gereinigt werden
kann dass sie beherrscht werden kann und
dass wir dann am montag sozusagen den
sicheren bewusstsein dass die welt
wieder in ordnung ist die woche neu
starten können also dieser sonntag ist
für den tatort ganz ganz extrem wichtig
einerseits und andererseits würde ich
sagen da tut macht wirklich immer das
gleiche man weiß was passiert gerade
diese spannung die eigentlich den krimi
auszeichnet ist von einer anderen weise
eine extreme berechenbarkeit in der
täter wird entlarvt ist es gar keine
frage ob er entlarvt wird und diese
beruhigungs funktion in der
krimigeschichte glaube ich es ganz
wichtig für die faszination des genres
sie haben aber meine frau hätte ein
bisschen umgangen nämlich die nach dem
signet also dieses jahr unverändert
geschichte aus den 1970 er jahre die
immer jeden sonntag ich habe es ganz
wichtig dass das signet eben das gleiche
geblieben ist es gab ja mal von til
schweiger einen vorstoss quasi diesen
diesen anfang zu ändern und das wurde
dann ziemlich entrüstet abgelehnt und
ich glaube zu recht denn auch das ist
einfach ein markenzeichen der tatort ist
die stärkste marke im deutschen
fernsehen und der marke darf man nicht
einfach so verändern und dann glaube ich
auch das signet also auch der der ton
das gehört einfach dazu also ich glaube
auch ganz ganz wesentlich vor allem weil
der tatort ja keine reihe eine kleine
serie in dem sinne ist das konstante
ermittler gebe sondern die wechseln
immer über die 40 jahre das einzige was
den tatort zum tatort macht sind
eigentlich zwei dinge es ist die musik
von klaus doldinger und es ist der
vorspann und der abstand der konstantes
und alles andere ist extrem diverse in
dem sinne dass natürlich auch ordentlich
ganz verschiedenes ist ja ein format das
innerhalb des deutschen sprachraumes
auch die ganzen lokalen eigenheiten
zeigt das heißt wenn man einen film
einfach sehen würde ohne vorspannung und
nachspann würde man ihn vielleicht gar
nicht ansehen dass es ein tatort ist er
sind nur diese drei identitäts anker die
die marke so beliebt machen und
natürlich auch eine gewisse
qualitätskontrolle die damit einhergeht
diese qualitätskontrolle quasi die hand
und sagt jetzt kommen dann
diddy diddy die kriminellen und die
kommissare und die toten und all das was
wir eigentlich eindämmen und versuchen
in unserer zivilisatorischen
kontrolle die musik aber das ist in
ihrem buch das sie mit andere nation
herausgegeben haben
interessant beschrieben beschreibt eben
dass man es quasi eingeführt wird in
etwas theoretisches also etwas was wir
nicht kontrollieren können das ist
eigentlich die subliminal message der
der einführung ja das ist ganz
interessant wenn sie diese legendäre
musik von klaus doldinger analysieren
das fängt mit einer quad an würde und
das ist in der musikgeschichte der
aufruf zur jagd er selbst eine
polizeisirene ist heute noch eine quad
das heißt es passiert etwas jemand wird
gewagt er gesagt das ist der polizei
aspekt der musik und dann sehen sie dass
die musik wandert in so einem dschungel
soul funk aspekt der uns in die
großstadt in das rotlichtmilieu und das
verbrechen führt und die wanderung der
musik zeigt eigentlich die dynamik des
tatorts an einerseits das aufklärungs
bedürfnis dann sehen sie in der
triebhaften großstadtdschungel welt in
der die verbrechen geschehen ganz am
ende kommt dann die grad wieder und im
abspann und das ist sehr interessant
wenn sie an der tatort denken ist dann
wieder die großstadt junge musik das
heißt das verbrechen geht auch weiter
das ist schon eine ankündigung des
nächsten fall ist und es ist ja kein
zufall wenn ein format so erfolgreich
ist dass dann die 34 identitäts anker
wirklich auch eine ganz besondere
qualität und tiefe haben und für diese
musik kann man das glaube ich unbedingt
sagen also das heißt wir haben es mit
einer scheinbaren idylle zu tun so wie
sie das eingangs beschrieben haben also
dass der nervenkitzel die angst die
mögliche panik doch immer latent präsent
bleibt und sich auch am montag nicht
auflöst ja es ist eine kontrollierte
furcht oder eine kontrollierte angst die
da dieser erzeugt wird und dass es
sicher in jedem tatort so dass die angst
einerseits geweckt wird aber eben
andererseits auch eingedämmt wird und
das ist die große beruhigende funktion
des tatorts der janney tief verunsichert
ist und dann immer eine gute lösung das
konzept ist auch so dass quasi nach
spätestens nach zehn minuten passiert er
darf eigentlich nicht später kommen ist
auch so eine ansage von also vom sender
und der mord wird dann in der restlichen
zeit gelöst oder manchmal viel auch
nicht ganz könnte auch sein zum beispiel
am nächsten sonntag
werden wir sonst nicht sagen weil ich
werde es bestimmt nicht sagt jetzt ganz
einfach es wurde gesagt dass wir eine
entwicklung der gesellschaft über diese
fasst der mehr als 40 jahre verfolgen
kann es natürlich wesentlich auch die
deutsche gesellschaft damit gemeint die
schweizer sind ein bisschen zaungäste
darauf kommen wir sicher noch zu
sprechen aber wenn wir quasi den tatort
als politisches schauspiel uns anschauen
also dass die gesellschaft auch einfluss
hat auf das handeln jedes einzelnen
korruption sind solche themen mafiöse
konstellationen usw auch im aktuellen
schweizer tatort wird das dann ein thema
sein also wie politisch ist eigentlich
dieses fernsehspielen
ich glaube es ist immer politischer
geworden es war ursprünglich weniger
politisch es sind heute glaube ich mehr
gesellschaftsrelevante themen die
behandelt werden und das ist glaube ich
auch ein erfolgsmerkmal dieses tatortes
das eben themen zum zuge kommen die
wirklich in der gesellschaft gesprochen
werden ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
der tatort themen setzen kann aber ich
glaube dass er sehr oft und immer
häufiger themen aufnimmt dienende
gesellschaft relevant sind also ich
denke auch diese spiegel funktionen
teilweise auch diese trends funktion die
der tat hat übernimmt es gibt jetzt
heutigen sonntag wird ein tatort
ausgestrahlt und christel mess und
altersarmut zwei große gesellschaftliche
themen die auch relativ neu sind und uns
viel zu denken geben bei den politischen
würde ich vielleicht mit einem
hubsteiger nicht ganz überein stimmen
denn der erste tatort war schon ein
deutsch deutsches thema es ging um die
deutsch deutsche grenze und innerhalb
des deutschen geschichte war diese
grenze problematik des grenzen
überschreiten für den tatort am anfang
etwas wichtiges und als zweites ist es
so dass es in deutschland in den 70er
jahren 972 eine strafrechtsreform gab wo
die ganze denkweise darüber was einen
kriminellen zu kriminellen macht und wie
man ihr zu bewerten hat sich verändert
hat und so war der tatort gerade am
anfang sehr bemüht soziologische milieus
freizulegen und den tätern als subjekte
auf die spur zu kommen was macht die
überhaupt zu kriminellen und das führt
dann jetzt glaube ich und sehr viele
explizit dazu die großen
gesellschaftlichen themen in dieser
analyse mit einbezogen
also das heißt politisch ja einen
eingeschränkten sinn weil es handelt
sich ja um fiktion ja es ist ja nicht
eine dokumentation aber vom politischen
wie ist dann der sprung zum
philosophischen also das politisch ist
verstehe ich aber das philosophisch er
ist mir noch nicht ganz klar also ich
glaube es ist ganz einfach so dass wenn
wir an die großen 56 begriffe denken die
unser leben tragen als handelnder als
moralische person schuld vergebung seine
freiheit klarheit das böse das finden
sie alles im tatort das heißt der mensch
als moralisches wesen kann sich in
diesen tätern in den ermittlern in den
vorgängen spiegeln und so ist ein tatort
immer auch selbst reflexion auf das was
hätte ich in dieser situation getan
handelt der kommissar hier richtig nach
welchen standards wird die braut
verfahren wird hier der täter nicht
ungerecht behandelt und ich glaube es
gibt immer die übertragung und das ist
natürlich wesentlich für das format das
man sich selbst auch imaginiert in diese
situation wie hätte ich gehandelt so
denke ich schon dass der tatort eine art
ethische schulung oder eine ethischen
reflexion anregt die dann auch auf den
sofas oder in den wohnzimmern auch
weitergehen oder ist es nicht auch so
dass
sie sagten vorhin dass der krimi
eigentlich das erfolgreichste
media ist die die moment zu haben ist
sowohl in büchern als auch im film dass
der mensch einfach so eine affinität zum
verbotenen zum geheimnisvollen hat und
und dass das deswegen auch so
erfolgreich ist weil man weil man ja
dieses geheimnisvolle oder dieses dieses
verbotene das reizt ein ich glaube jeder
hat in seinem leben schon mal kurz
zumindest vielleicht nicht ernsthaft
aber kurz darüber nachgedacht jemanden
umzubringen oder eine bank zu überfallen
oder irgend etwas in der richtung zu
machen und sie sich outen
also ich glaube ist also wie ich glaube
dass das ich da nicht der einzige bin
das passiert doch jeden mal also auch
als kind wenn man eine totale wut hat
weil man irgendwas von den eltern nicht
bekommt dann könnte man am liebsten die
ja morden oder ausreißen oder was auch
immer also ganz generell ist natürlich
glaube ich ein ein fixum menschlichen
verhaltens man gibt ihm eine regel und
er wird diese regel überschreiten er
wird den drang haben diese regel zu
überschreiten ja wenn sie es aber in
einem großen kontext sind jetzt
kulturhistorisch etwa um 1800 kommt die
kriminalgeschichte das ist natürlich der
punkt an dem die aufklärung die größte
wucht die größte schlagkraft hat und
allein der begriff aufklärung ist ein
begriff der natürlich doppelsinnig ist
es geht im tatort darum dass etwas
aufgeklärt wird vom dunkel ins licht
gebracht wird vom triebhaften in die
vernunft von der unordnung in die
ordnung und das ist das was aufklärung
im philosophischen kulturellen sinne
sein wollte die dunklen triebe der
unvernunft ins licht der vernunft zu
führen und uns alle zu vernünftigen
menschen zu machen und so ist der krimi
als genre vielleicht so eine kleine
rebellion oder eine erinnerung daran
dass da immer noch ein kleines tierchen
ein teufelchen in uns steckt das sich
nicht so leicht und nicht vollständig
ins licht führen weil die die
faszination für das böse
ob sieg oder omnipräsent ist nicht durch
die aufklärung des quasi bestimmt auch
schon vorher oder also vielleicht jetzt
so die kriminalgeschichte an und für
sich aber wenn man jetzt zum beispiel
denkt shakespeares macbeth oder
schiller die räuber oder das böse kommt
ja eigentlich in der literatur oder auch
in der theaterliteratur
ist schon immer vorgekommen ja das
stimmt wobei es natürlich am anfang
sogar dass das böse ein bisschen 1800 er
ein höfisches böses war das waren die
mächtigen die böse waren und dort gibt
es eine art demokratisierung des bösen
das heißt es sind eigentlich ein
jedermann der zu diesem verbrecher
werden kann was einfach mit der
demokratisierung unserer gesellschaft
glaube ich zu tun hat also wir sind
glaube ich in diesem sinne angehalten
nicht nur zu denken dass die mächtigen
böse sind sondern dass das böse in uns
selber steckt wenn sie jetzt an die
deutsche problematik denken und auch den
tatort erst mal als deutsches phänomen
sehen so ist natürlich als deutscher
auch geschichtlich besonders dafür
sensibilisiert dass dieses böse in uns
steckt dass es gedeckt werden kann und
dass auch jeder dafür anfällig ist denke
dass es auch etwas aus meinem kontext
des tatorts vielleicht bedenken kann
also die banalisierung des bösen über
das format eines fernsehkrimis sicher
also ich glaube dass in der deutschen
gesellschaft und vielleicht auch in der
deutschsprachigen
geschichtlich ein besonderes eine
besondere sensibilität tafel herrscht
wie anfällig die verführung fähig man
als einzelnes individuum in gewissen
kontexten ist und der tatort ist eine
weise zu inszenieren unter welchen
bedingungen menschen überhaupt böse
werden oder denen sie es tun auf die
dunkle seite an und vielleicht ist es
auch noch ganz banal einfach so man hat
die möglichkeit der tatort ist ja ein
unterhaltungsformat man hat die
möglichkeit sich selber auf die
tätersuche zu begeben
der böse wird meistens bestraft am
schluss ich glaube das ist auch ganz
wichtig man fasst ihn und er wird
bestraft und das ist einfach auch eine
art von ja guter spannender unterhaltung
also dass das was auf dem buchdeckel
ihres buches steht nämlich schlauer
werden mit der beliebten fernsehserie
würden sie das unterschreiben sind sie
selber jetzt schlauer geworden durch
ihre direkte arbeit am tatort also ich
glaube jetzt schlauer geworden glaube
ich nicht dass ich bin aber
man wird mit themen konfrontiert die die
mich interessieren aber ich glaube
schlauer werden glauben sie dass man
schlauer werden haben einen tatort ich
habe oft das gefühl dass ich zugang zur
milieus erhalte natürlich fiktionalen
und geschönt in die ich sonst nicht ein
einblick habe das scheint mir mal so gut
recherchiert also soziologisch werde ich
schlauer und natürlich bin ich aktiv als
als zu sehen wie bei anderen formaten
nicht unbedingt was sie sagt ich bin ja
angehalten selbst zu ermitteln der
zuschauer ist ja auch in der
mittlerrolle kriegt das raus stellt sich
die frage so dass das krimigenre ein
genre ist das einerseits ist der
ermittler da und dann weiß er das lösen
andererseits sind wir alle ermittelt es
gibt kein passiven tatort so sehr die
aktivität ist immer auch die aktivität
des zuschauers ich habe das stichwort
gegeben dass man einblicke bekommt in
situationen gegenden die man nicht kennt
die young nicht zum eigenen alltag
gehören vermutliches der schweizer hat
wird so ein gutes beispiel für sie die
der sich aus deutschland kommen also die
frage nach der setzung von themen die
eigentlich aktuell sind die aber doch
überraschend sind für eine größere
gemeinschaft dort hat es immer wieder
geschafft sexueller missbrauch als
gesellschaftlicher tabus kamen im tatort
vor drogen gewalt in familien zerrüttete
familien und so weiter und so fort der
kommende schweizer tatort hat ein
typisch schweizerisches thema und da
möchten wir kurz eine sequenz mit ihnen
anschauen ja gut so
bleiben sie sitzen
herr behrens flückiger für informationen
die einvernahme wird auch die visuelle
aufgezeichnet ich bin sehr froh hier zu
sein
das wollte mich das will ich in diesem
raum sie müssen mehr helfen erzählen sie
mal was heute morgen passiert ist sie
sind kurz nach halb acht es ist
furchtbar sie müssen wir helfen
wie kann ich ihn 11 ich würde kein
telefonieren geht das
wollen sie ihren anwalt anrufen
ist das der it
es falsch verbunden herr behrens
sie stehen unter dringendem verdacht zu
seine straub hoch gebracht zu haben ist
ihnen das klar ist
ihnen das klar
man will auch nicht umbringen hier ist
der einzige ort wo ich sicher bin
jetzt erzählen sie mir was heute morgen
passiert ist
ich habe gegen 7 uhr das haus verlassen
so wie immer um zur arbeit zu gehen
als ich aus der tür trat wurde ich
bereits erwartet von markus reich liegen
vom bankhaus von bildern und was hat der
von ihnen gehaltenen auf den kopf
zugesagt dass sie alles wissen sie haben
herausgefunden dass sich die daten habe
er hat mir gedroht moment moment was für
daten die kontodaten der offshore kunden
unserer bank
sie haben kundendaten von der bank von
wem geklaut nein keine einfachen daten
dass die gesamten daten der
wirtschaftlich berechtigten person die
ich in der internationalen stiftung
entstehen die von der bank von wien auf
den cayman islands verwaltet werden das
ist ein ausgeklügeltes system diese bank
versucht alles um die namen der kunden
hinter komplizierten firmenkonstrukt
verschwinden zu lassen sie hätte so beim
steuerbetrug rechnen dann ihre gewinne
über eigene tochterfirmen klein
herr behrens
sie stehen unter dringendem mordverdacht
da sind verbrecher schwerverbrecher er
während es ist meine pflicht ist
ich sorge für aufklärung
wo sind die kontodaten diesen safe an
einem sicheren
an einem sicheren ort in der schweiz
jetzt haben wir gesehen wir sind hier
ebenso in einem völlig anonymisierten
verhörer also wir sind weg von dem
klischee luzern und der schönen aussicht
könnte diese szene irgendwo spielen oder
ist das wirklich sehr schweizerisch es
ist insofern schweizerisch dass das
thema schweizerische schweizerisch ist
also gar datenklau auf und kontodaten
hat vorwiegend ihren der schweiz
stattgefunden von dem er
hat das vielleicht in deutschland jetzt
so in österreich nicht gegeben aber
ansonsten jetzt ein von der räumlichkeit
her oder so könnte das überall
stattfinden dh es gibt eine gewisse
angleichung also der lokalkolorit
zurückgefahren um vielleicht dem
klischee ist zu vermeiden ja ich glaube
es ist viel einfacher auch mann mann
mann dreht fiktion wir machen
unterhaltung und fiktion und wir denken
eigentlich nicht in jeder szene darüber
nach ist das jetzt schweizerisch oder
ist es nicht schweizerisch wir nehmen
ein schweizer thema was hier stattfindet
oder stattgefunden hat und behandeln das
thema und dadurch dass wir in der
schweiz drehen das in sozialen drehen
gibt es gibt es einen einen schweizer
lokalkolorit aber es ist nicht immer
quasi der aufpasser hinnimmt im
hinterkopf ist das jetzt schweizerisch
oder ist das jetzt nicht schweizerisch
denn wir sind ein sprachraum wir sind so
verschieden von den deutschen sind ja
gar nicht auch wenn wir es vielleicht
manchmal gerne hätten oder von den
österreichern also wird das ist der
alemannischen sprachraum und so so groß
sind die unterschiede da gar nicht sie
nicken einem ich würde einerseits sagen
dass ich nie darauf verzichten wollte
als tatort zuseher das lokalkolorit
gelöscht zu finden also es ist so dass
der tatort der davon lebt dass er dieses
lokalkolorit hat es gibt eine föderale
struktur jedes bundesland hat einen
tatort jedes deutschsprachige land hat
einen tatort und man sieht das ja auch
um diese lokalkolorit zu atmen zu spüren
und die spezifische situation zu sehen
andere welt und ich denke das zeigt
dieser szene natürlich wunderbar gibt es
so etwas wie diese lokalisation
einerseits ist lokal verortet
andererseits ist es ein globales thema
und das thema das jetzt besprechen im
besonderen sind ja da geht es bis zu den
cayman islands und ist nach hamburg und
in die ganze welt und das würde ich
jetzt wiederum sehen ist für die schweiz
besonders
geschickt und meiner ansicht nach
plausibel gewählt weil die schweiz
vielleicht sage ich da nicht so viel wie
eine art kristallisationspunkt auch von
globalen verbrecher von globalen
geldwäsche von globaler kriminalität ist
und andererseits und das finde ich auch
sehr interessant es ist ja ein anonymes
verbrechen diese bank verbrecher haben
ja gar kein gesicht das sind
strukturelle verbrechen die sind ganz
ganz verschiedenen netzwerken bewegen
und das ist besonders anforderungs reich
und in diesem fall auch besonders gut
gelungen denke ich dass man diese
strukturelle kriminalität
personalisierte dass man ihr ein gesicht
gibt man kriegt sie ja als person gar
nicht zu fassen weil man sieht ja auch
dieser täter der täter sein soll es
eigentlich ein opfer und es gibt kein
ort mehr an dem er sicher ist das ganze
thema überwachung ist ja auch in dieser
szene mit angespielt und in dem sinne
glaube ich dass wenn sie jetzt diese
szene nehmen das hätten sie 1980 nicht
gehabt 1970 das ist auch eine szene die
nur
2013/2014 überhaupt sinn ergibt und da
ist der tatort auch ein symptom unserer
zeit und da wird wirklich viel sichtbar
über das was uns heute im handeln
bedingt aber da werden wir wieder ein
bisschen bei der in diele von der sie
eingangs gesprochen haben weil so
einfach ist die welt nicht dass man eben
den bösen ein gesicht geben kann wie im
tatort
also dass ihr die beruhigungs funktion
also wenn man geht es ein idol ideologie
kritiker sein wollte würde man sagen der
tatort ist sind guter hinsicht oder in
vielerlei hinsicht schlecht die
ideologie weil es bei der uns weismachen
dass es einen täter gibt den wir fangen
können wenn sie an eine these wie von
hannah arendt über die banalität des
bösen denken ihr punkt ist dass in der
modernen gesellschaft das böse kein
gesicht mehr hat das niemand mehr ein
einzelner täter ist sondern dass die
strukturen selbst böse sind aber die
strukturen kann man nicht verhaften was
man ja an diesem tatort dann auch sehr
klar sieht ja
also diese personalisierung des bösen
die neigt auch dazu uns vom wesentlichen
abzulenken und vielleicht ist das auch
eine funktion des tatorts dass wir es
gerne haben dass das böse ein gesicht
hat weil wir ahnen dass das eigentlich
böse gesichtslose unerreichbar mich
würde interessieren wie man seinen
tatort vorbereitet also ab welchem
moment hat man ein thema und wann ist
dann dieses thema am fernsehen weil sie
die entwicklung eines tatortes dauert
ungefähr ein jahr das heißt ein autor im
zusammenhang mit der redaktion vom
schweizer fernsehen
hat eine idee dann wird ein papier
erarbeitet eine seite dann wird über das
diskutiert dann sagt man ja das ist ein
relevantes thema das das möchten wir
gerne vertiefen dann schreibt der autor
in zusammenarbeit auch mit der redaktion
ein treatment und wenn das treatment gut
ist das sind dann etwa 30 seiten da ist
die quasi der ganze film schon relativ
detailliert aufgeführt dann geht man ins
drehbuch das dauert circa ein halbes bis
ein dreiviertel jahr wenn man das
drehbuch hat gibt es meistens mehrere
fassungen der regisseur schaltet sich
ein sagt das gefällt mir nicht oder das
gefällt mir vielleicht nicht da muss
noch was geändert werden oder so dann
setzten sich die drei parteien zusammen
und es wird wieder eine neue fassung
erstellt wenn dann die endgültige
fassung da ist bereitet man circa zwei
monate vor da sind dann schon ca ich
sage 15 bis 20 leute involviert dann
kommt eine drehzeit die dauert fünf
wochen da sind dann circa 50 bis 60
leute involviert und dann gibt es die
postproduktion wo die nachvertonung die
synchronisation die musik der schnitt
die das color grading das heißt man
passt die farben an der look etc wo das
alles bestimmt wird und das dauert dann
nochmals ca drei monate und dann ist der
film fertig und dann ist ungefähr ein
jahr vergangen quasi von der ersten idee
bis zur fertigen fertigstellung des
films und da gibt es aber so eine art
über dramaturgie dass man jetzt nicht
zweimal die banken zum thema
hintereinander am sonntag es gibt es
gibt eine koordinationsstelle in
deutschland für den tatort und dort
werden diese bücher quasi eingereicht
die werden dort auch abgenommen und die
sagen dass sie ihn jetzt zum beispiel
wenn wir jetzt gerade zwei morde haben
irgendwie im drogenmilieu oder so dann
schauen die entweder dass das eine nicht
gemacht wird oder dass die beiden filme
nicht irgendwie gleichzeitig zur
ausstrahlung also hinter kurz
hintereinander ausstrahlen und welche
steuerungs 8 haben denn die kommissare
selbst innerhalb dieser rahmen
entwicklung also man weiß vom deutschen
tatort in münster dass beispielsweise
die kommissare da oder die schauspieler
starken einfluss nehmen können wir
dürfen wie würden sie diese sehen das
dürfen wir eigentlich auch also wir
haben immer eine sitzung mit der
redaktion im vorfeld wenn das buch noch
nicht fertig ist und dann besprechen wir
darüber stimmt das auch jetzt für uns
als kommissar meistens ist es ja so der
schauspieler der die figur spielt der
kennt seine figur einfach im westen und
es ist sinnvoll dann auch mal zusammen
zu sitzen mit dem schauspielern zu sagen
stimmt dass für die figur was jetzt da
passiert oder wie er reagiert oder
stimmt dass er weniger und da haben wir
sehr wohl einen einfluss darauf wo wir
keinen einfluss drauf haben und das ist
auch nicht unser geschäft ist quasi in
der in der grundidee und in der
erstellung des drehbuchs das gibt es
autoren dass das ist deren business ich
würde auch sagen wenn sie jetzt diese 40
jahre tatort sehen wie sie sich
entwickelt haben es gibt in der
dramaturgie in der drehbuchentwicklung
schon eine große tendenz der letzten 15
jahre und die würde man in der
fachsprache den be brought nennen das
heißt dass die eigentliche aufklärung
des verbrechens nicht mehr das einzige
oder auch das dominante spannungsmoment
ist sondern die privat geschichten und
die lebensumstände der ermittler als
person die sind manchmal traumatisiert
weil sie ihre familie verloren haben die
haben selbst der drogenabhängigkeit die
lassen sich gerade scheiden haben
sorgerechts streitereien das heißt der
tatort hat sich in der handlungs
entwicklung eigentlich ein wenig weg nur
von der verbrechensaufklärung entwickelt
hin zu einer tiefen darstellung der
ermittler als selbst problematischer
persönlichkeiten da gibt es natürlich
einen prototypen also sie geben mir
wirklich das stichwort wunderbar nämlich
schimanski und ich glaube es gibt ein
forschungs könnten nach schimanski und
wir haben eine sequenz vorbereitet aus
der ersten reihe schauen wir mal kurz
rein
und der tod
haschmann menschen die der polizeifunk
haften sie ab jetzt immer verschließen
den qualm auf
du liegst schon wieder mit dem ankommen
höher auf ja ich weiß
wie schon das bild einer zeitung von
diesem
ansturm an der leiche doppelpunkt
die frage drängt sich auf wie viel
schimanski steckten flückiger
also ist würde ich sagen
würde ich verneinen ich habe meine
eigene figur kreiert die mit schimanski
nichts zu tun hat was man vielleicht
vergleichen könnte ist als der
schimanski gekommen ist kam das ganze so
ein bisschen in die in die tiefen der
realität rein so wird gesprochen auf der
straße so wird umgangssprachlich
miteinander umgegangen
und das hat er im grund genommen glaube
ich als einer der ersten in diesem
tatort reingebracht und das ist heute
natürlich anders das braucht man nicht
mehr neu zu erfinden heute ist man viel
umgangssprachlich unterwegs also die
bücher werden auch schon so geschrieben
ich glaube was man ja diesen 80er jahren
sieht es natürlich dass schimanski auch
eine form von ungebrochener männlichkeit
ist die heute so ohne weiteres gar nicht
mehr plausibel zu machen ja also nicht
nur dass wir viele ermittler teams haben
und mehr weibliche ermittler insgesamt
was natürlich auch eine
gesellschaftliche umschwung ist aber
dieser effekt männlichkeit die mit
gewalt arbeitet die dieses hormon
ausstrahlung von testosteron hat wenn
sie heute die ermittler sehen die
männlichen das sind oft geschwächte
männer eher schwache männer fast
metrosexuelle männer könnte man sagen
und das hat auch glaube ich eine riesen
umschwung in der in der erwartung unter
dem bild dessen was einen männlichen
oder weiblichen ermittler weiter aus das
sehr interessant weil das hat sich
wirklich total verändert auch in der
gesellschaft heute hat ein mann eine
ganz andere haltung auch zu seinen
problemen oder zu sein sprechen also es
wird eigentlich immer darauf hingewiesen
auch von der psychologie oder von der
soziologie her dass ein mann zu seinen
schwächen stehen soll dass er schwächen
haben darf und das war früher in den in
den 80er jahren oder 60er jahren oder so
war es bestimmt nicht der fall also hat
sich bestimmt her und das auftauchen
wirklich tatsächlich der kommissarinnen
also sie sind
mit der yamaha zusammen mit mitteln des
rechtsstaats diese kombination die
konstellation dass private das nicht
existente privat das geheimnis darum
herum die erotischen aspekte tauchen auf
und zeigen eben auch fragen diese
schwächen diese schwächen decken sich
auch wieder vielleicht eben mit einer
kollektiven befindlichkeit
weil wir uns wiedererkennen in diesen
gebrochenen
metrosexuellen gestalten drin aber
flückiger ist ja eher noch so ein
bisschen auch dieser dieser hart
gesottene dieser dieser männliche typus
es geht eigentlich also die tendenz
ihnen folgen ist jetzt auch das hat man
schon letztes mal gesehen oder sieht man
auch jetzt in der neuen folge dass er so
ein bisschen auch in der lebenskrise
hinein schlitte dass er sich plötzlich
bewusst wird er hat das ganze leben lang
für die arbeit hin gegeben er hat
beziehungen nicht gepflegt er hat keine
kinder das ist für ihn auch ein thema
das er plötzlich sieht ja ist kann es
dass sein ist es das alles also quasi
muss sich um die arbeit zu kümmern und
da kommt ja auch so ein bisschen in
strudel und in gewiss die stromkreise ja
und auch da ist natürlich sehr
symptomatisch für fast alle tatort
ermittelt das privatleben ist nicht
intakt weil sie ständig auf abruf
ständig bereit ständig in der arbeit
sind und dann sind diese kommissar
dynamiken die sind ja jetzt nicht
vereinzelt so das gilt ja fast für jeden
arbeitenden menschen für war so dass nur
der arzt und der kommissar angerufen
werden konnte unsere arbeit musste heute
sind wir in dem sinne fast alle ein
bisschen kommissare geworden weil wir
ständig diese arbeit dynamik des immer
bereit sein immer auf dem sprung immer
den nächsten fall haben und das bietet
die zerstörerisch das im privatleben
aussieht das sieht man bei fast allen
tatort kommissare es gibt kaum einen mit
einer intakten familie
die meisten haben auch keinen sex leben
mehr und wenn sie kinder haben ist das
immer extrem problematisch also dass die
krise des arbeitenden mannes und und
auch die krise des mannes in seiner
rolle die lässt sich an den tatort
kommissaren derzeit glaube ich ganz ganz
ganz stark ablesen und philosophisch wie
würden sie das jetzt einbinden ihren
philosophischen
es hat sicher etwas mit einer großen
bewegung zu tun die wir auch sehen und
das ist ist die frage was aus dem mann
wird wenn die frau die rechte erhält die
ihr nach unserem gerechtigkeitsempfinden
zu stehen und das andere was ich glaube
ich auch sehr interessant findet sie
umsorgen ermitteln frauen eigentlich
anders als männer wir sprachen hier von
der aufklärung die ratio gilt das was
der man klassischerweise hatte und dass
er gefühle empfinden das intuitive das
sprach man sehr lange in unserer kultur
den frauen zu und ist das denn so in den
in den tatort darstellungen haben die
frauen an anderen ermittlung stil haben
sie andere intuitionen gehen sie an dass
im verhör um also weiblichkeit und
männlichkeit ideale ihre verschiebung da
ist der tatort wirklich ein
paradebeispiel dafür
also jetzt im einen fall ist es so dass
der flüchtige auch sehr seiner intuition
vertraut also dass der auch sehr seinem
bauchgefühl wahrnimmt und auch intuitiv
oft dinge erfasst während jetzt zum
beispiel in unserer kombination die
delia mayer die die liz ritschard spielt
er die die ist dies komplett analysiert
und von dieser seite her kommt also die
rollen haben sich da fast ein bisschen
vertauscht na ja also ich denke ich bin
ich jetzt den schweizer typus er das ist
ja ein männlicher schweiger er schweigt
er sehr viel er guckt sehr lange und die
frau ist tatsächlich jetzt in ihrer
dynamik glaube ich eher die harte die
regel geleitete und die robuste während
sie in ihrer person oft eine gewisse
anfälligkeit und auch eine gewisse zeit
zeigen die sich die frau gar nicht
erlauben will oder kann also ist eine
ganz interessante fast eine kreuzung der
klassischen geschlechter dynamik und wie
schaut sie mit dem mit dem mörderinnen
und mördern aus also wenn man sagt die
männer die kommissare werden durch ihren
job depressiv oder haben diese diese
latenz zur depression schon drin die
sinnkrise was machen wir eigentlich oder
es kommt zu dem tatort oftmals vor dass
verlangsamen das aussteigen wollen die
sehnsüchte wegzugehen abzudriften das
ist da die frau und die quasi in die
institution immer noch den weg in die
institutionen hineingehen sich behaupten
dem job alles opfern unterordnen in den
das privatleben zur seite legen also da
sind wir schon auch so ein bisschen in
stereotypen drin jetzt die täter haben
sie die gleiche sinnlosigkeit in der
existenz wie die polizisten
glaube ich
glaube nicht dass sich die täter
irgendwie groß verändert haben also
in der hinsicht natürlich sieht man das
bei den tätern auch die
gesellschaftliche dynamik die dahinter
steht also dass ich diese
geschlechterrollen eben verändern also
das wird man beim täter genauso sehen
aber
das ist eigentlich ähnlich wie bei den
kommissaren burkhard spinnen deutsche
schriftsteller dann einen schönen
aufsatz geschrieben für die welt und
darin schreibt er auch über diese idylle
und sagt dass es eine sub tendenz gibt
dass man in den tatort zählen immer mehr
den mächtigen an den kragen gehen dass
einerseits gibt es immer weniger
machtfülle weil wir weil weil die die
präsenz und die überwachung auch da
funktioniert und dass es anonyme wird
dass man diese macht ein gesicht geben
kann aber wir hassen die mächtigen weil
sie so tun als hätten sie macht und die
müssen wir symbolisch kaputt machen also
macht das in der realität mit einem
bundespräsidenten wohl man macht es aber
jeden sonntagabend auch tendenziell am
fernsehen das heißt dass die milieu
verschiebung weg vom schrebergarten mord
hin zum willen mord immer immer
deutlicher wird und und dezidierter wird
also die diese bewegung lässt sich
ablesen
ist natürlich der kriminalgeschichte an
sich als genre eingeschrieben es gibt
von einem deutschen kulturphilosophen
siegfried kracauer aus den 20er jahren
ein sehr schönes der kriminalroman oder
sagt wenn der böse erfolgreich ist dann
wird er zu einer art gott gestalt er
führt uns an der nase macht etwas wasser
nicht davon wird dafür nicht bestraft
das heißt eine unbestraft hat verbrecher
der ist eine eine dominante eine
unheimliche eine große streit in dem
moment in dem wir ihn kriegen ist er
klein ist noch kleiner als wir sind und
dieses bestreben das unheimlich große
das machtvolle dass wir nicht erreichen
können auf den boden des regelwerks zu
holen diese entlassung die hat natürlich
auch bei der macht man wenn man
natürlich heute vielleicht richtig oder
falsch war er davon ausgeht dass die da
oben alle dreck am stecken haben weil
sonst wären sie ja gar nicht da oben und
diese herunter holen auf den auf den
alltäglichen bezug unserer regeln dass
es sicher auch ein gewisser lustgewinn
der der am tatort immer stattfindet
wobei ich glaube eigentlich nicht ich
glaube nicht dass ich das wirklich so
stark verschiebt also dass jetzt
plötzlich in den villen mehr ermittelt
wird als in irgendeiner anderen medien
ich hab sogar eher das gefühl dass in
den in den in den krimis der der 90er
oder 80er jahre wie derrick oder wie der
alte oder so dass die oft in besseren
kreisen gespielt haben aber dass der tat
dort eigentlich eher dazu tendierten in
ein anderes milieu hinein zu schauen
also in
er so ein bisschen in die proletarischen
ja genau ja
wobei man natürlich eine spannung glaube
ich ganz stark war andi muss die den
tatort in zukunft meiner ansicht nach
bedingen wird es wird ja immer schwerer
verbrechen zu sein es wird immer
schwerer nicht erwischt zu werden es
wird immer schwerer überhaupt nicht
beobachtet zu werden das heißt die logik
des verbrechens selbst erfordert glaube
ich heute von einem mann der nicht
erwischt oder von einer frau sehr viel
mehr insofern würde ich denken wir
brauchen zunehmend clevere sehr
raffinierte sehr technisch gewitzte
verbrecher und der kleinen dieb oder
derjenige der immer ortbar wäre mit
seinem handy die ist eigentlich zu
schnell gefasst ich denke so die die
verbrecher bestreitet die muss sich
ändern weil unsere technischen
möglichkeiten der ermittlung unter
überwachung so sind dass die netze immer
enger gespannt werden für das verbrechen
also das heißt es braucht doch eine
unglaubliche kompetenz und vermutlich
dann auch ökonomische mittel um das
ideale verbrechen zu begehen die er
unbedingt aber der perfekte verbrecher
das ist ja schon immer so gewesen der
muss ja fast an gott sein weil er alle
kontingents nannte zufälligkeiten alles
im voraus berechnen muss das kann ein
mensch nicht das kann höchstens der
liebe gott und er ist ja bekanntlich
lieb
und also wenn wir wenn wir es nochmals
auf auslegen als wir haben einerseits
moriarty oder dem großen bösen und wir
haben sherlock holmes und klugen guten
und die grenzen verschwimmen oftmals
also dass sich in den tatort serie
dieses verhört dass wir gesehen hatten
lief noch ziemlich glimpflich ab oftmals
wird beanstandet von polizeireporter die
sich einen tatort anschauen dass
polizisten die so agieren würden in der
realität sofort versetzt würden
entlassen würden und dass vor gericht
überhaupt keine aussage so akzeptiert
und gültig wenn also die realität von
der sie gesprochen haben diesen
realitätsbezug vom tatort zur welt wie
sie stattfindet ist doch letztlich große
fiktion das darf man nie vergessen also
das sagen wir auch oft leuten die jetzt
unseren tatort kommentieren oder irgend
etwas sehen was vielleicht nicht ganz
der realität entspricht das muss platz
haben dürfen also wir machen fiktion wir
machen unterhaltung und es kann nicht so
sein also wenn man das jetzt genau der
realität abbilden würde dann würden sich
die leute zu tode langweilen und
spätestens nach 20 minuten abschalten
also es ist film und es ist fiktion also
darf man zum beispiel sie sind in luzern
ich habe ich nicht nötig sich um
polizisten ich habe mich natürlich
richtig vorbereitet darauf ich habe mit
sehr vielen kriminalisten gesprochen ich
hab schießtraining gehabt ich lerne die
wii fast man jemanden an diese dinge
müssen schon stimmen also wenn ich
irgendwie eine viertelstunde habe um
irgendwelche handschellen anzulegen dann
ist das natürlich ganz schlecht aber es
gibt dinge wo ein wo es ein anderes
gesetz gibt wo sein filmisches gesetz
gibt und wo dieses gesetz höher bewertet
wird als dass es jetzt genau so in der
realität
gewesen wären vielleicht kann man da
auch wirklich mal aristoteles zitieren
der die erste poetik die erste
dramaturgie geschrieben hat und hat
gesagt es ist gut dass das
unwahrscheinliche manchmal auch
wahrscheinlich ist das heißt wir wissen
auch von unserem leben das manchmal
dinge passieren die eigentlich gar nicht
sein können und ein drama wäre kein
drama wenn es nicht auf diese
unwahrscheinlichkeiten zusteuern würde
und zuspitzen würde und rechtlich ist es
natürlich sowieso so dass bei vielen
tatorts ein staatsanwalt oder ein
kommissar sich die haare straff was dort
durch geht was dort gemacht wird aber da
sehen wir auch glaube ich die erwartung
hatte ein zuschauer nicht der will in
dieser fiktion er erst mal dramatisch
unterhalten werden und die realitaet
zumutung
die sollte man sich da nicht so nicht so
stellen was glaube ich sehr sehr
beachtenswert ist dass die kommissare
selbst den tätern immer mehr ähneln die
also früher war es ja so artmann sind
wir doch da in dieser richtung oder das
gibt es alles dem gleichen spital krank
sind als hin losigkeit aber auch dann
letztlich also normalerweise nehmen wir
an der mensch ist gut und irgendwas muss
passieren damit der böse wird das ist
auch beim tatort oft rudi hat ein trauma
der täter er wurde geschlagen als kind
da muss seine mutter retten und wir
haben jetzt mal oft kommissare die
wurden auch geschlagen die haben auch
eine familie verloren die haben auch
kein geld so dass man eigentlich sagen
könnte unterkommen könnte eigentlich
genauso gut der verbrecher seien die
ähneln sich die gleichen sich an
manchmal umarmen sie sich auch und
verstehen sich einander viel besser als
sie sollten also da würde ich auch eine
so eine große verschiebung sehen dass
die kommissare täter und ermittler die
werden sich immer ähnlicher vielleicht
liegt es daran dass wir uns alle
zunehmend als leicht geschädigt
empfinden
und gerade diese diese städte und finde
ich schon sehr interessant wenn man sagt
vielleicht gibt es ja doch noch mal so
eine tendenz jetzt die man herauslesen
kann vielleicht nicht die mit dem milieu
aber die rolle der kriminellen als
diesem anonymen komplexen konstrukt
eines marian ist alles weiß alles kann
und man irgendwo erwischten die
polizisten die in einer emotionalen
psychologischen sinnkrise sind und in
einer depression und die eigentlich
diesen tagen nicht gewachsen sind aber
die angleichung braucht für den plot der
identifikation zwischen den beiden
kategorien des guten und des bösen und
dass man dann das jetzt ein bisschen
vielleicht ein bisschen mutig diese
sinnlosigkeit überspielen muss indem man
wieder neue harte kerle einbaut also sie
haben nur sehr weil schweiger also jetzt
kommt plötzlich wieder so brutal ins
kies gehen mit dem schießeisen sich 90
minuten durch die szene ballung und das
gute doch herstellen aber das sind ja
nicht raffinierte sherlock holmes typ
hat sich wahrscheinlich also ich glaube
das ist ein ganz normaler vorgang wenn
so viele teams unterwegs sind dass da
irgendwann mal einer dabei ist der sagt
ich möchte gern wo das so funktionieren
grundsätzlich glaube ich hat sich das
stark verändert in den letzten 40 jahren
das früher hat man im fernsehen oder im
film viel lieber erhellten figuren
gesehen und heute tendiert man eher dazu
wenn einer wirklich der held ist das ja
unglaubwürdig wird dass man sagt der hat
ja irgendwo auch schwächen oder abgründe
und diese gibt man ihn dann jetzt bei
til schweiger hat ich glaube das liegt
auch an ihm selber weil er sich das
vielleicht sogar als bedingungen
ausbedungen hat dass er gesagt hat wenn
ich damit mache dann will ich soundso
uhr spielen dann wirklich action machen
mehr bedient jetzt zum beispiel das dass
er das amerikanische vorbild oder das
amerikanische kino ich finde das völlig
in ordnung weil es gibt so viele leute
und die einen die den ist vielleicht das
lieber den anderen vielleicht ist ein
axel milberg der sehr psychologisch
vorgeht als als borowski lieber oder
oder dieser oder jener also so kommt
jeder zu sein und zu seinem cremig das
bringt uns also jeder findet seinen
krimi im theater und das scheint ja
offensichtlich zustimmen also wenn wir
uns fragen wer schaut tatort dann sind
das ja millionen und und arbeit
millionen die das schauen wir haben
übrigens eine kleine rechnung gemacht
vorhin als ich hierher kam ich habe
immer ausgerechnet es gibt 915 folgen
wenn im schnitt jede folge 8 millionen
menschen gesehen haben was gut möglich
ist da die ja alle x-mal wiederholt
werden dann haben bis jetzt wenn man es
verteilen würde auf verschiedene
menschen 7,2 milliarden menschen schon
mal einen tatort gesehen dort ist für
die ganze welt jetzt schon das können
wir sagen ja doppelt sogar
das ist ja nicht die ganze wenn wir
nochmals nein ich glaube am sonntagabend
wenn ich mich nicht irre also ist eine
these stimmt vielleicht nicht aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen hat die frau die
fernbedienung in der hand und
entscheidet die frau was geguckt wird
wenn vielleicht nicht gerade sport läuft
könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen
also ich glaube auch dass man spricht ja
immer von diesen medialen lagerfeuer und
was diese funktion nach erfüllen kann
das ist tatsächlich einer der wenigen
gelegenheiten in denen die familie als
familie sofern die kinder älter als
zwölf jahren sind doch mal zusammenkommt
und sich als familie empfindet wenn sie
dieses eine format
hat dass alle schätzen und dass alle
gucken können und es ist ja nicht nur so
man schaut ja dinge nicht einmal am
inhalt interessiert ist man schaut sie
auch im büro am nächsten montag darüber
sprechen zu können ja umarrangiert zu
sein im gespräch zu sein und da gibt es
wirklich ganz wenige medial ereignisse
fußballspiele und der tatort wo man nur
ungern ins büro gehen möchte und sagt
ich habe keine ahnung wovon die anderen
reden das heißt ganz platt ausgedrückt
man schaut das einfach auch deswegen
weil es die anderen schauen und dieses
plateau dass der tatort sich jetzt
erkämpft hat über 40 jahre das wird auch
halten weil diese funktion in jeder
gesellschaft in jeder gruppe von
menschen wichtig ist es gibt etwas
worüber man sprechen muss das über das
wetter hinausgeht und im
deutschsprachigen raum es ist am montag
sehr auf der tatort wie machen sie es am
montag nach einem tat oder nach ein
nachdem sie mit immerhin
es ist für mich ein ganz normaler tag
auch ich bekomme häufig sms von von
bekannten freunden verwandten kollegen
oder oder ruft mich jemand an und sonst
ist alles eigentlich ganz normal aber
ich begebe mich jetzt also nicht fit und
twitter ist für mich keine option
auch facebook nicht ich bin da ein
bisschen konservativ irgendwie ich finde
twitter das ist einfach so oberflächlich
was da an kurz futter weltweit
verbreitet wird das ist gar nicht meine
sache und und auch online kommentare das
so dass das lesen aber die bedürfnisse
also wenn wir den medientheoretiker
marshall mcluhan bitte bemühen möchten
und sagen dem medium is the message das
medium ist die ist die messe dass man
sagt es geht eigentlich um diese familie
die sich auf dem karton sonntag trifft
und und und das zusammen erlebt und uns
zusammengeschweißt jetzt gibt aber quasi
über das medium die große das große
lagerfeuer dass man wähle man tatort zu
einer gemeinschaft gehört und das wird
natürlich über die sozialen medien noch
bestätigt das ist natürlich wird
intensiviert also bei mir ist es so ich
bin auf facebook und auf twitter und ich
habe kollegen die quasi minütlich eine
art live ticker für den tatort senden
und das kann sehr amüsant sein und das
kann auch eine gemeinschaft stiften wie
es überhaupt die ganzen rezeptions
bedingung des tatort sich im begriff
sind natürlich zu ändern es ist jetzt
abrufbar es ist so dass es öffentliche
public viewings in deutschland gibt in
fast jeder stadt in der man in der
kneipe das guck da wird dieser kult
charakter wie beim eurovision song
contest fast da geht es nicht um die
handlung sondern macht sich eben lustig
weil man sich gemütlich macht wenn man
mit jemanden dem man schon kennt aber
insgesamt ist diese funktion des
sonntags 20 uhr die für den tatort
konstitutiv wichtig bedeutend ist dies
insofern gefährdet als die abrufbarkeit
und die verlagerung auf mobile medien
dazu führt dass die zeitliche
konzentration die den tatort bisher
geprägt hat die wird sich wahrscheinlich
in zukunft auslösen und dass es aber
eine
bewegung die sie in allen inhaltlich
getragenen medien haben das heißt das
jetzt erlebnis das verschwimmt zu einer
breiten fläche
von wochen oder monaten in denen dieses
feld wahrgenommen werden kreis wage ich
zu bezweifeln ich glaube dass der
sonntagabend dann ziemlich fester wert
ist also dass man am sonntagabend ist ja
eben die das wochenende zu ende die
meisten leute sind dann zu hause und
dass der tatort also ich kenne ganz
viele leute die gucken den tatort
wirklich live und nicht zoomen und nicht
auf der mediathek natürlich wird es auf
der mediathek und wird das
wahrscheinlich sich vergrößern und das
ist bestimmt unbestreitbar aber ich
glaube nicht dass das das so auseinander
fallen wird dass man quasi sagen könnte
genau so viele menschen schauen sich den
tatort auf dem ipad an wir haben und auf
dem fernseher ist glaube ich nicht sie
haben jetzt beide
nochmals gesagt dass der tatort nicht
gefährdet ist in diesem
millionenschaden drin gibt es nicht doch
gefangen kann diese blase nicht platzen
einer immobilienblase platzt weil sie
haben es auch erwähnt 400 material ein
tatort über die bildschirme läuft
die gefahr besteht vielleicht schon das
irgendwann mal zu viel des guten
gesendet wird das weiß ich nicht im
moment was ich aus deutschland höhere
ist der halb so groß wie ich wir nie war
also der tatort war noch nie so so
gehabt eigentlich bei den medien sowohl
als auch bei den zuschauern wie die
letzten jahre
also das heißt wir werden immer noch in
diesem prozess mit dabei sein schlauer
zu werden weil der tatort wird weitere
40 jahre über den bildschirm laufen ich
glaube der tatort wird bleiben aber er
ist gefährdet und zum beispiel im zuge
des verfassens dieses buches habe ich
mit sehr vielen gesprochen die sagen ich
schau kann tatort mehr schau breaking
bad ist also warschau die amerikanischen
serien ich glaube also nicht dass der
tat auch ein eigener übersättigung
stirbt sondern nach qualitativ
hochwertigen bedrohen alle anderen und
sie formal hat nämlich der serie die
wirklich seriell arbeite mit 17 folgen
die auf einander thematisch gehen und da
da ist die bedrohung für den tatort
einfach neue fernsehformate auf der
gleichen qualität liegen zum schluss
möchte ich etwas fragen was sie wirklich
den fernsehzuschauern zwar schon mit
geben könnten sie haben beide große
erfahrung mit dem format tatort wie
erkennt man einen mörder rheinberger der
norderstedt in der ersten einstellung in
der auftritt in jedem zentrum der kamera
also ich würde als kommissar natürlich
sagen erstens soll man den täter nicht
erkennen und zweitens
könnte es der seien von dem man es am
wenigsten vermutet
stefan gubser hallenberg ich danke ihnen
für das gespräch